the year 1883 the problem rats in Hawaii
are damaging valuable sugar crops the
solution control the runes by
introducing a new predatory species the
small Indian Mongoose sounds like let's
be honest we all know where this is
going it turns out rats are generally
nocturnal while the small Indian
Mongoose is active during the day so the
two species rarely met lucky for the
Mongo's monges monges whatever lucky for
them Hawaii is is full of appetizing
native Wildlife including sea turtle
eggs and numerous species of endangered
birds with no natural Predators the
mongen thrived 100 years later they
remain a massive problem on many of the
islands but now hear me out maybe if we
introduce cobras